so recently disneyland laid off 20 000
employees in southern california
everybody looked at bob iger
the executive chairman of the board how
dare you lay off 28 000 people in disney
these are people that need jobs they're
feeding their families their kids but
what if i told you it wasn't disney's
fault
what if i told you was governor newsome
who laid off 28
000 people because today we're gonna
measure two parks
one is disneyland based out of
california the other one is disney world
based out of florida both same company
two different states
what kind of decisions were made simply
based on
politics
[Music]
you know a lot of times capitalism gets
a black guy all these people that all
they care about is
money you know they let people go they
have no feelings
they're cold-blooded people these
capitalists they don't
really care about the families that are
working very hard but many times they're
forced to make decisions because for me
i say never judge politicians i don't
sit there and say
barack obama this donald trump this push
this
clinton this knew some this desantis
this but
always judge politicians policies one
more time
never judge politicians but always judge
your policies because what do their
politics
policies produce we got california we
got florida here disneyland is in orange
county california
disney world is in orange county florida
right it's funny orange cow orange
county
this one's orlando this one's orange
county southern california santa ana
anaheim area right okay
the governor of california is governor
gavin newsom the governor of florida's
governor ron desantis
california is over regulation friendly
they're all about over-regulating so
when the covet happened they're like
no we got a over regular you can't go
out you can't go to restaurants close
down restaurants if the top's not open
you can't go out there and eat
regulation regulation regulation
florida is business friendly they're
like listen we got to figure out a way
to make sure these businesses last
because if they don't
we're going to have a big problem here
so what happens to the disney to
disneyland in california
they closed on march 14th disney world
closed on march
15. they closed one day after remember
same ceo
bob chapic i believe is the ceo's name
same everything but two separate states
two separate states same seal right
they close on the 14th they close on the
15th
they're still closed 200 days later
disneyland in california
is still close till today i believe
disneyland
started in july 17 1955 if i'm not gonna
say yeah july 17 1955
do you know since 1955 that's 65
years ago do you know how many days
total disneyland's ever been closed in
years you ready five days let me say
this one more time
only five days have they ever been
closed
since 1955. now they've been closed over
200 days
under the leadership of governor newsom
these guys
disney world officially opened up magic
kingdom opened up july 11th
uh animal kingdom open up july 11th as
well epcot and hollywood studios open up
july 15. let's continue so now watch
this this is very important for people
to understand the optics
of what a disneyland or a disney world
does to your state if you're the
governor ready disneyland there was a
study done
back in 2018 by cal state fullerton
funded by disney but cal state fullerton
did the study
and they came up with a conclusion that
in 2018 alone
disneyland generated 8.5
billion dollars of economic activity
plus
78 000 jobs let me say this one more
time
disneyland has 78 000 employees in the
state of california that worked for them
and created 8.5 billion dollars of
economic activity now watch this
this is just one dimensional right we
don't look at how many
vendors partners other people that are
making money so it's not just 78 000
jobs that's probably
300 000 jobs that we're talking about
that people are making money
off of this thing but this is 78 000
employees working for them forget about
the contract with pepsi
coca-cola drinks bread all this stuff
that's being delivered nope
that's just this and what they're doing
for the state of california now florida
watch this
the cfo florida chief econo economist
officer of florida
does an audit and says disney world
alone
has 77 000 jobs created
in the state of florida and there's
sales revenue
tax sales tax revenue that came to the
state of florida alone
is 700 million dollars let me say this
one more time just the sales revenue
from taxes from sales tax
is 700 million dollars can you imagine
if you're the governor of florida you're
saying man we love disney world
if you're the governor of california man
we love disneyland don't you want to
make sure these things stick around but
not governor newsome
watch what newsome did on october 1st on
october 1st this is just a few weeks ago
california governor newsom announced
that they will not be opening
any theme parks they're not going to be
opening any theme parks
two hours after he announced this
bob iger the former 15-year ceo of
disney now the current executive
chairman of the board
resigns from their economic team that
have put together the task force
resigns two hours later and then disney
announces they're letting go of
28 000 jobs in
the state of california disney some
people say disney bar bikers such greedy
people
nope it was a byproduct of the governor
governor is the reason why they had to
let go of 20 000 people by the way
people have to realize this bob iger is
not a republican
bob iger is a democrat if you read his
book bob iger at the end of his book
when he sits down i believe with uh the
leader of fox at the time and they were
getting ready to buy fox
and the fox leader i think it's murdoch
i don't know which one it is mordock
asks him
do you have any plans of running for
office and he was actually thinking
about running for office
he said i don't have any plans of
running for office bob iger is a
democrat because of his family his mom
and dad he was a democrat because of his
parents he's loyal to his parents
policies
and he stuck to it two democrats go head
to head
newsom democrat iger democrat wait a
minute what are you doing you put me to
create jobs and make sure california
moves ahead
but you're making this thing keep going
what do i i can't keep
these people a policy income boom 20 000
people get fired
two two hours after the announcement
that's made so that's this guy now watch
what newsom said here's what newsome
said
about bob iger and bob chapex decision
from disney
newsome said there is disagreements in
terms of opening
a major theme park we're going to be
led by health first framework
and we're going to be stubborn about it
when he said
we have differences with me and bob iger
can you imagine we're
going to be stubborn about it 28
000 people lost the job because of bob
iger not because of a governor newsome
now some people may say well pat
do what are you trying to say should
they open it up
should they leave it open should they
bring the jobs back here's what you have
to understand with these two stories
right here okay both states
that we're talking about they did
another research here saying the fact
that 87 million
people around the world come to disney
world every year
and 2019 was 87 million people the same
number is close to here
can you imagine how these two brands the
kind of money and the kind of people
they're attracting
to their states there was one
entrepreneur
who owns a pizza shop in both of these
cities in orlando by disney world and in
anaheim
by disneyland named daryl maliki daryl
maliki owns pizza shops
he says his pizza shop near disneyland
is down 90 percent his pizza shop
near disney world is only down 30
percent this one is staying open
this one's about to close down he's
making no money he's frustrated saying
listen i understand protecting the
people out there
but you got to keep give us an
opportunity to survive as business
owners as well
this whole thing i shared with you the
article was written by wall street
journal we're going to put the link
below for you to read
but when you watch this here i will tell
you from bob iger
if i'm the executive chairman of say
disney and i'm sitting there saying huh
recently we just saw mba come out and
say black lives matter
blm everywhere on the floor everywhere
it says blm blm blm
advertisement after advertisement after
advertisement
vote vote vote and mba is known as
predominantly
push everything to one side their envy
is not necessarily republican
they're very democratic you can't go
i've never seen a player in the nba
being able to get away with
wearing a mag i've never seen it if
you're in the nba you have to be on one
side
if you're in the nfl at least a brady
can say i'm friends with trump and get
criticized for it but he is
you know and mlb same thing but in nba
it's all one-sided right so viewership
dropped 64
people are now watching the finals but
do you know what's the interesting thing
about the nba huh
watch this here do you know
which state the nba decided to have
their playoffs which which state they
put the bubble in
did they put it in anaheim california
very left-driven state
or did they put it in orlando huh
why did they put it in orlando oh
because
orlando is not like newsom over regulate
orlando said you can come and do the nba
playoffs here
can you imagine if the nba wanted to do
that here
the amount of regulation so all the
policies
that they support are policies of
newsome yet they create the nba league
in the state of florida because it's
more
business friendly and the nba is a
business they're trying to get their
business going
they can't do it in the state of
california but they can do a state of
florida
as a person who's a registered
independent myself
i voted for clinton's and i voted on the
right
and i voted on both sides of policies
for myself i see things on one side that
needs to be rearranged and i see things
on one side
but if there's one thing i'm not a fan
of it's contradiction and hypocrisy and
you see a lot of that
in the state of california i've lived
there for 24 years here's some feedback
if anybody from bob iger's camp is
watching this if some of you guys decide
to tweet this at bob i've read his book
i've recommended it
i think everybody in the world needs to
read his book anybody and everybody if
you're not read this book you need to
read it
put the link below as well for his book
if you haven't read it yet but i will
tell you this if i'm bob iger
if i'm disney and i'm watching this and
i'm sick of
what the politics and the policies
of california are producing because you
got to judge policies
policies 28 000 jobs policies
park open 87 million people around the
world come to orlando
imagine what that does to the city of
orlando if you want a simple shop over
there
or hotel or restaurant you don't think
that benefits you that benefits you
but if bob i grow and anybody from the
disney's campus watching this
you know what my recommendation is to
you mr bob iger or bob japek or any one
of you guys here's my recommendation to
you
there is a state right next to you
i think it's called nevada and nevada
just got the oakland raiders
la raiders when i think about raiders i
think about oakland or la i don't think
about any other state
but the raiders went to nevada and
they're going to be attracting a lot of
players i don't know how well they're
going to do this season i like their
coach but they're probably going to
end up doing very well you know why no
taxes
so what if a disneyland
makes a massive announcement saying
we're spending a few billion dollars
building a park there's a lot of land
over there in vegas
you buy a couple thousand acres of land
you decide you're building a disneyland
in vegas coming out five years from now
and you launch it
no taxes you get tax break you negotiate
all the stuff for 20 years
for what you want to do vegas is a
tourist city
vegas is becoming the kind of place now
families are going to it it's not just a
place that only young party people go to
it
and now you've got a disneyland over
there and you don't pay taxes and
regulation is going to be on your side
i tell you one thing governor newsom you
just better hope disney doesn't hear
this message and you
better hope disney doesn't buy into this
message because if they do
you're about to lose disneyland due to
your policies
that keep pushing business people out
that's what happened to the state of
california state i love
i love the state of california but i
cannot stand the policies that are being
pushed
in the state of california where it's
getting all these people that at a time
like this when you're going through
crisis
you know what sometimes i got my two
boys sitting right here next to me i got
my seven-year-old what's your name
and i got my eight-year-old what's your
name ah these guys we went to la to go
to
universal studios they just want to go
to universal studios
at times like this kids just want to go
to park you mean to tell
me you couldn't come up with a better
policy to have more hand sanitizers
and testing and measurements to allow
people to go to a park
you mean to tell me you couldn't do
something like that you mean to tell me
you can't say well listen we're going to
open up disneyland
but when you come in extra measures
maybe you have to get tested for covid
within whatever time
consumers would spend the money to get
tested to go do it
we would spend the money because we need
entertainment for our kids
and you're saying no to it is it
politics you're playing
are you making policies that are good
for families so what's more important to
you governor newsom
policies or families what is it make up
your mind
because if it's truly families you're
losing your own people
bob iger is a democrat bob iger was
a fan of obama bob iger was somebody
that's helped a lot of people on your
side out
and you're losing a person like that two
hours later he resigns that's the wrong
kind of person to lose in the state of
california
i hope that somebody from vegas nevada
if i'm the governor of nevada making one
phone call
hey bob can we talk yes can we get you
another bob on the call both of you yes
how much longer you want to be bullied
by politicians in the state of
california
do you think this is going to change
anytime soon no well why don't we look
at vegas
come and take a look at to see what we
can do look at raiders go talk to the
raiders owner see if they're happy
why don't we make something work over
here for you no state taxes
no crazy regulation what do you want to
do let's make this work oh
if that even happens if you ever see
this announcement happen that
disneyland is considering a move to
vegas don't forget this video when it
was shot if that ever happens
i hope this message goes to the right
people because california keeps bullying
business owners
and eventually if you lose your number
one employee you already lost your
number one podcaster in the world
you already lost your number one
innovator visionary in the world
you know what his name is and if you
lose your number one employer
you cannot keep number ones you become a
country an estate
essentially it's a country fifth biggest
economy you can only keep
yes people you can't keep leaders like a
joe
like an elan and a bob if you lose the
third one which is disney world
massive exit is around the corner so
look if you're watching and say pat i
totally disagree with you great i want
to hear from you comment below
pat i fully agree with you comment below
send me a tweet let me know if you
disagree or agree
i'm not really worried if you agree with
me i want to hear your argument for both
sides having said that two other videos
i want you to watch
if you enjoy this message here one of
them is 10 reasons why i support
capitalism
if you've not watched it's a complete
different angle i give click over you to
watch it the other one is 10 reasons for
you to consider
moving to a different state if you've
not watched either one of these click on
that
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye